I'm excited to be here of course because
we are on television all of us I have
always wanted people though to look at
me and think to themselves I bet she's a
wildcat in the sack I've always wanted
that and no one's ever done that no
one's ever thought that no one's ever
said that and it's because it isn't true
you guys because you know what I am in
the sack a lot like I am on stage which
is hardworking and earnest it makes up
makes up for a lot makes up for a lot
but I am married and that's weird and
it's only weird because I don't have any
social skills and I've never had any
social skills but I am married because
the best invention the worst invention
the best invention online dating yes
prior the online dating if I liked a guy
this is all I used to hit on guy so used
to stand next to them for years
it isn't good it isn't good it does not
get you dates but I am NOT good with men
but I'm excellent with computers so I am
married but everything I know about
being in a relationship I know from
stand-up comedy there I've been doing
Santa County for 30 years and there are
three main jokes that guys tell about
their wives sometimes they're funny
sometimes they are not but do not kid
yourself they're the same three jokes
joke number one once you get married
woman's stop having sex with you man
it's the way it goes it's the way it
goes joke number two once you get
married women spend all your money man
it's where it goes that's where it goes
joke number three [ __ ] man
am I right [ __ ]
yes so I have spent the last several
years of my life
essentially a making sure everyone
getting enough in the sack right are we
all getting enough in the sack to try to
leave his money alone as much as I
possibly can which is actually quite
difficult as he has a regular job and
then three if I have a negative emotion
I like to stuff it cuz that never
backfires see yeah but there I did learn
other things that were real that's
interesting I'm gonna that's gonna be
great
we are in this together you guys okay so
but I did learn other things there are
other jokes that are real the listening
joke was real that they always told I
didn't know this but it's true once you
heard a relationship for an undetermined
amount of time you stopped hearing what
is being said to you sometimes
conversations wash over you and you
guess an answer as you can imagine me
with the but it that it that it he does
it all the time but recently we were in
the car together he was talking but it
did it and I said yeah yeah he'll do it
over you want he goes really and I was
like what just happened what am i when I
say yes to turns out we were discussing
something sexual and he said so you
would wear a costume in bed and I was
like what kind of costume would you want
me to wear in bed and he goes duh shark
I promise you he said shark we don't
know why we don't know why I said shark
I think he said sure cuz he didn't know
that I would say yes and he had to come
up with something in the moment that was
not terrifying because obviously a woman
could not wear a shark costume and have
sex because you can't back that ass up I
don't know if you are familiar with the
movement of sharks but they cannot swim
backwards if you're gonna roleplay an
animal no it's physical limitations
you want to be an elephant that's great
but they got to be on top cuz they can't
look up I don't make the rules I don't
make the rules but he knows what he's
doing I am married to an adult man who
has had short term relationships and
long term relationships like a person
it's great not long ago
I said in this tone of voice to him I
feel like I'm being a burden and he did
a thing that I recommend you do if
you're ever in a relationship with me he
laughed in my face he didn't laugh at me
he just laughed and he said a pretty
sure that's what marriage is I think
that's it we're gonna be a burden on
each other forever he knows things now
long ago he also were sitting around and
I looked up and he said you know
sometimes when you're in a relationship
for a long time the mystery can be lost
from that relationship and I just want
you to know that I was just staring at
you from across the room and I was
thinking to myself what the hell is she
doing so I still got it you guys have
still got
[Applause]
furious so fantastic
you